hi my name is Yvonne orgy and actual hey
Mai hi my name is Alexander Hodge and
I'm playing Andrew okay so as you know
Molly and Andrew net on episode 5 of
season 3 at the Coachella so since then
you know Molly's kind of I could figure
out she wants to go the other route
Lloyd comes to dating and she has
decided to give it a go yeah I just
think it's funny how in Episode two
Molly's talking about how she wants to
spend more time more quality time with
Andrew and learn more about I'm in an
episode for she just really I feel like
that's the plight of the strong black
woman like so I can be successful at
work yeah like shift adapt I'm flexible
I think I understand I think he's doing
his best so at the dinner when I wanted
to make plans with you and you had
already made plans with your friends
like Molly felt slighted by that Andrew
was assuming based off of previous
interactions previous circumstances that
it would just follow the way it had been
I think Molly would just appreciate it
if he you know Castle this one instead
he killed his girl so why did she tell
him not to do it so that he could do it
anyway like so we see now like this this
is this is where the truth of it comes
the reverse psychology of it all uh I
got lost in translation now there was
access to Rio just now I'm sorry just
didn't know computer oh is that what it
is - Rio God well I guess be gonna see
what's gonna happen with us season we're
gonna see how Andrews rights and Molly
learns a lot and it's just a really
beautiful thing
[Music]
you